i have a number of things i want to go
over with you today and the first one is
a really strange reason
to oppose helping homeless people that
this is just bizarre
uh in the state of tennessee
they've been debating a bill dealing
with homelessness
and in the midst of the debate
republican state senator frank nicely
stood up he's from strawberry plains
tennessee
and he said hey you know what
being homeless isn't the end of the
world
hitler
hitler
was able to
do things and make something of himself
even after being homeless for a little
while now he's not saying killing jews
is good but why do you go to hitler as
an example of someone who
entered the history books after being
homeless it's bizarre speaker i haven't
given you all the history lesson in a
while and i want to give you a little
history on homelessness please 19 and 10
hitler decided to live on the streets
for a while
so for two years hitler lived on the
streets and practiced his oratory and
his body language and how to connect
with pieces and then went on to lead our
life that got him in the history book so
a lot of these people it's not a dead
end they can come out of this these
homeless camps and have a productive
life
or in hitler's case a very unproductive
life
um
guys i i get he's not saying you know it
was delightful hitler was homeless and
then he came out and he was able to kill
six million jews i get that he's not
saying that
but why do you have to point to hitler
and also if hitler chose to be homeless
in order to practice his oratory skills
and uh and body language most homeless
people are not trying to build public
speaking uh skills by by being homeless
mention you know the singer jewel at one
point was really living in her car she
really was horrible backstory to it or
actor jim carrey once lived in his car
on his sister's front lawn although it's
not even really being homeless in the
sense that a lot of people are homeless
or
why why hitler
and it's this very strange
it's it's not an obsession but it's like
why why are they thinking of hitler so
much to make positive points
and here the point is listen it's not
that bad to be in these homeless camps
uh people can end up
in the history books even after being
homeless
look at hitler these people are very
strange and i think that there's
something extraordinarily wrong with
them
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video